hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between adult anderson and paul
charles morphe the legendary clash
between the uh so-called old and the new
world uh and uh the first three games
ended well by uh anderson win the first
game the second game ended in a draw and
then morphe was able to score his first
win uh in the third game and
i don't know if i mentioned this but
morphy's physician was only present for
the first two games and after the first
two games he said it all right it seems
that you're getting better no no
need for me to uh you know stay any
longer and the number of visitors that
could actually enjoy the games as the
games were played in morphy's room uh
but were transferred uh in the the cafe
de la regence uh on i think three boards
three or more uh since of course they
didn't have any streaming services they
would have a courier and then he would
update the moves every half an hour he
would go to the room check out the board
and then you know probably record it or
maybe if he was a chess player himself
maybe he would even
uh remember it but um
he probably recorded it and then he came
back downstairs to cafe de la chance and
then he you know transferred the moves
on all three boards so there were a lot
of spectators on this match just not
directly viewing the the games but there
were a few joes and gentlemen that were
allowed to to participate i think some
eight eight or ten of them uh we're
going to discuss that a little bit more
uh deeper into the match so getting back
to this game this is game four and
they're repeating the position from game
two uh where you know it was a really
really uh fun game the royal opus where
anderson had some chances but let's see
what happens in this one so understand
again with the white pieces opens with
e4 we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6
and the bishop to b5 uh again going for
the royal opus we have a6 morphe goes
for morphy's defense uh bishop to a4
knight to f6 and now d3 again going for
the anderson variation against morphy's
defense uh bishop to c5 c3 and b5 so
we're completely repeating the moves
from the second game of the match bishop
to c2 and now uh morphe strikes in the
center with the d5 uh we've talked a bit
more about uh
some of the positions that happen here
in uh the video for game two so if you
haven't seen it do check it out if
you're interested a little bit more so e
captures on d5 knight captures and now
h3 not allowing bishop to g4 we have
castles by uh morphy and castles by
anderson and now h6 of course taking
away the g5 square from anderson's
bishop uh and d4 now attacking the
bishop ended the pawn here e capture c
captures and now bishop back to b6 with
knights to c3 and now knight uh b is
coming to d4 so now we already mentioned
in the previous video if a3 then we hang
the bishop so bishop to b1 has to be pl
you don't hang it but you you know give
it up for a knight and this is a
spectacular piece you know especially
paired with this bishop so you do not
want to trade it so bishop to e6 by
morphy we mentioned why bishop to b7 is
not as optimal as bishop to e6 now you
want to trade this knight for this
knight at some point and then place your
bishop on d5 that's the idea so a3
knight to d5 you don't get anything by
trading because black would really enjoy
having his bishop on d5
and in that um game two that we
mentioned knight the e2 was played by
anderson but here he plays bishop to e3
and it is now as of move 16 that we have
uh well a completely new game but also a
deviation from from game two of their
match
so knights to f6 by morphe and now queen
to d2 so developing the queen now we
still have to figure out how to get the
rook into the game
uh rook to e8 by morphy now rook to d1
uh and now bishop to d5 uh this bishop
the d5 is is fine for morphe but bishop
to b3 uh could directly take advantage
of this rook on d1 it's it's a very
interesting move because now
either white moves the rook and then we
play bishop to b5 for example if you
really wanted your bishop on d5 or if
white uh doesn't want to waste the tempo
then he has to trade off the light
square bishops and this is kind of a win
for black because the white slice square
bishop is always stronger than black
slide square bishop in this particular
line so after rook to d1 morphy goes for
bishop to d5 right away and now comes
knight to e5 uh anderson could also just
go for a trade here knight captures
queen captures and then bishop to a2
sort of a way to get this rook into the
game for free and now i've queen e6
rocket rook uh not the b1 but rook a to
c1 and it could be
could be very nice for anderson but
anderson is
always a very uh very decisive in in his
ideas so he goes knight to e5 he really
wants to get rid of this knight and
somehow get his queen and bishop to
operate on this diagonal uh so queen to
d6 by morphe developing the queen
connecting the rooks and now queen to c2
uh we're getting the queen to this
beautiful diagonal now at some point he
probably wants to play some like queen
g4 trait of this knight and then deliver
queen to h7
but there is one problem here and there
is one move that morphy can play here
that kind of ruins anderson's plans so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's queen to g6 i'm
just kidding it's it's black to move uh
it's knight captures on d4 that's that's
the good stuff and now the problem is
you remove the defender of the e5 knight
and
that simply
uh works wonders for black but this is
what anderson was going for as his only
goal is to win this uh
h7 square for his queen so he eliminates
the knight bishop captures on d4 we have
bishop captures and now knight captures
on d5 asking what do you want to do now
we have queen captures an e5 if you go
for something like queen captures on d5
instead then knight to c6 is is is is a
pretty big issue for black because
there's a well a double attack on the
bishop now and there's no really no good
way to uh to defend against this so
instead after knight captures on v5 we
have queen captures on e5 and now
anderson finally eliminates the defender
of the h7 square he plays knight
captures on f6 with czech queen captures
and now queen to h7 with check so we
reach the position from the thumbnail
hopefully uh and uh
well now what can morphe do there is
only one move king to f8 and how do we
evaluate the position now well morphe is
up upon but anderson has his queen on h7
so is this a plus uh or
uh it is actually anderson um
just uh you know down upon here without
any serious compensation the problem is
you can't just continue attacking queen
hh checking e7 rook to e1 check for
example king to d7 and your queen is
attacked your f2 pawn is attacked so
everything is just hanging here this
would be completely winning for morphy
so instead after king to f8 we have
bishop to e4 now uh
connecting the rooks developing a piece
here with an attack on the rook here the
problem is you cannot capture because
rook queen a8 okay we can just show it
captures check king e7 we're going to
capture on a8 attack the rook here and
even if queen captures on f2 king h1
we're still better here attacking the
rook here the rook moves the fourth rank
we're also putting pressure on the
bishop uh if if the bishop moves you
have queen to d8 to check so it's uh uh
if anything white should be better here
uh and uh not only that he's up the
exchange so instead after bishop to e4
we have rook a to d8 by morphy and now
comes king to h1 not allowing this
capture to come with check
because now if you go for queen captures
on f2 then anderson has this rook to f1
idea and he could well harass the queen
a little bit and the double up on the
file for example queen g3 we're gonna
keep harassing the queen queen g5 rookie
to f1 and the black is still better but
you know maybe not allowing this is the
way to go so after king to h1 morphy
just plays bishop captures on b2 he
grabs another pawn and he asks anderson
uh where where is your attack a good sir
uh anderson uh moves the rook we have
rook to b1 now attacking the bishop here
and rook captures on b1 with check rook
captures and now queen captures an f2
grabbing yet another pawn uh and uh well
again asking uh unders
asking um
anderson where is the attack exactly and
there's no good way to approach this
for example if you try something like
rook to d7 frank trying to get queen to
h8 to checkmate in uh it's a white who's
getting checkmated queen e1 check king
to h2 and bishop to e5 check is deadly
there's no good way of defending this g3
we're going to play queen captures king
h1 and now queen to h2 will be checkmate
so instead after queen captures on f2 we
have queen to h8 to check right away
king to e7 and now well not a good
continuation for anderson he has to go
back queen to h7 but at least he blocked
the rook's uh influence along the e file
so bishop back to e5 by morphy now with
the simple idea of queen g3 queen to h2
checkmate and not much for uh for
anderson to to do there so bishop to f3
but now queen to g3 as planned
threatening checkmate king to g1
preventing checkmate and now there are a
couple of ways you could approach this
um
uh one one very interesting idea is just
bishop the d4 check is very much
possible now if the the rook captures
that queen the e1 check and now after
king to h2 we can play this check and
pick up the rook so one of the
possibilities uh but morphy plays it in
the absolute simplest way uh well almost
uh if capoblanca was playing it he just
placed queen to g6 uh he says all right
there's no need to complicate this any
further this is a very important match
let's just trade queens i'm up three
pawns this is completely winning for me
so i understand uh without really a
choice here a queen captures on g6 f
captures and now bishop to b7 if he can
reclaim a pawn or two uh then the
bishops are of opposite color if he
could grab a pawn or to trade off a pair
of rooks you know could be it could be
that he will be able to get a draw this
game but morphy just plays rook to b8
and he says nope that's not happening so
now you either move the bishop and then
my position is just better or you accept
this uh challenge and well that's not
going to end well for you but for the
lack of a better move anderson grabs the
pawn and now c6 and this bishop is now
trapped here and it's
going to be very very difficult to get
it out so king to f2
bishop to d6 now blocking off the rook
from the default so now the king can
cross uh we rook to d3 now comes king d7
uh we have king e2 rook to a8 now
attacking the bishop here bishop to b7
and now uh rook captures an a3 so if
white trades then well you don't really
have all that much here uh yes it's
still bishops of opposite colors but
after captures and captures it's just a
very very ugly position for example king
to d2 we're going to play king c7 and
our bishop here doesn't have a good
square bishop to a6 and it's pretty much
stuck there
without uh
without any hope of ever getting out uh
okay if we attack it you can go bishop
back to see it but we're not gonna
attack it we're just gonna you know uh
keep it cool and once the king goes over
to the king side for example then we're
gonna start pushing our queen side pawns
many many ways to win this end game
so instead after rook captures on a3 uh
anderson tried to bishop the c8 to check
we have king to c7 not uh going for
characters and captures and now uh rook
to d1 again not going for the trade here
we have rook to a2 check king to f3 and
now bishop to c5 going after rook to f2
check we have bishop to e6 now going for
rook to d7 check to maybe try and pick
off some king side pawns and now rook to
f2 with king g3 and now rook to f6
putting pressure on the bishop here
rook the d7 check king to b6 and now the
bishop has to move so you don't have
time to start grabbing pawns bishop g4
and now bishop to d6 with check and now
all of these squares are taken away from
the
from the white king the only square is
uh king to h4 so king to h4 is played
and now c5 morphe just starts advancing
his pass pawn bishop to f3 now going for
some bishop rook to b7 action but just
c4 morphe doesn't care he's just gonna
shift his king over here uh so rook
captures on g7 grabbing one pawn but now
rook to f4 with check we have bishop to
g4 and now you could win this many ways
you could play h5
uh morphy just continues advancing his
past pawn so c3 we have g3 attacking the
rook and now morphy uh ends the game uh
in well uh in great style with just rook
captures on g4 and he was in this
position on move 51 that uh adolf
anderson resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here once the
rook is captured regardless so what
would you capture it with we're just
going to play c2 next move promoter pawn
to a queen and that's it there's no no
move that white can play to
even even try to you know do something
about this
uh and okay you could go for some like
captures we're gonna bring a queen into
the game you might even capture the
bishop here king to c5 but the resulting
endgame is still winning for for black
you know just pushing this point is
enough to win if you guys were
interested so yeah after real captures
on g4 anderson resigns and morphe takes
the lead in the match so uh by losing
the first and drawing the second game
morphe now wins game three and game four
and we'll see what happens the next in
the match will anderson be able to
bounce back or will he be another victim
of morphys after morphy uh played weekly
uh you know for for the first and second
game although murphy didn't play weekly
anderson just played a brilliant game
let's let's be real
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh be ready for game five
very very soon uh i would like to thank
benjamin wilson uh john locke with david
kimura henry wilson and marshall ferrier
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day